hey 42 here in the year 2000 a small
budget japanese film by the name of
battle royale was released to great
controversy
with several countries going so far as
to ban the movie outright that probably
had something to do with the film's
unusual premise
in which a bunch of kids are gassed
during a school trip then taken to a
remote island where they're forced to
fight to the death
yeah not exactly disney is it
even if you've never heard of battle
royale which these days is considered a
cult classic by the way
the plot may well still be familiar to
you that's because it bears a striking
resemblance to one of the biggest book
film franchises of the last couple of
decades the hunger games
both stories are incredibly bloody and
brutal and according to millions of fans
around the world pretty darn
entertaining too but neither the hunger
games nor battle royale has ever been
accused of being overly realistic a load
of random people dumped on an island in
the middle of nowhere and forced to
fight to the death
it just couldn't happen in real life
except
it turns out
it already has
and the real-life version of the hunger
games was much
much worse than anything that's ever
been dreamt up by the fertile mind of a
creative writer
this video is sponsored by x sheets bed
sheets for gamers after a long day of
gaming you need rest and now you can get
it with that sheets the only led powered
bed sheets made for gamers enjoy maximum
nighttime visibility and supercharge
your circadian rhythm available now at
extremerest.com only joking this video
is actually sponsored by rage shadow
legends obviously raid is the first game
to bring a true console level experience
to your phone they've set the bar high
and there's no going back with hundreds
of artifacts to equip and over 600
champions blessed with unique skills you
can build your team develop your
champions and raid your way so what's
new in raid well raid's currently
running a special deliana chase event
where you can get your hands on the
amazing deliana a brand new legendary
champion from the high elves faction
just by logging in all you have to do is
log in and play raid for seven days
between now and july the 20th and you'll
get deliana for free and this is the
best time to get started in raid all you
have to do is click the link in the
description and scan my qr code here on
the screen and you'll get a free starter
pack worth almost forty dollars we're
talking three free champions at once
mizeracord tiger soul and romero plus
ten magic xp brews 10 force xp brews and
10 spirit brews that's huge they gave
only one champion out in the past so
don't miss out on your chance to get
such big rewards this time all this
treasure will be waiting for you here
new players listen up once you're in
game just enter promo code my deliana to
get your hands on everything you'll get
50 xp bruce who instantly get your
legendary hero deliana to the max level
of 50 as well as a ton of silver and
i'll see you in game
when soviet leader joseph stalin had six
and a half thousand prisoners dumped on
a remote siberian island in the 1930s
without food or water
what happened next was so flat-out
disturbing that efforts were made to
erase any record of the events from the
history books altogether
this is a story of stalin's cannibal
island one of history's most horrific
examples
of what happens when you push human
beings far beyond their breaking point
as far as eggs go joseph stalin was a
particularly bad one in fact if
history's most evil dictators were made
into top trumps stalin would be fighting
it out with the likes of hitler and
polpot for the title of best card in the
deck or worst
he rose to become general secretary of
the communist party of the soviet union
in 1922
and amongst other things he used those
early years to consolidate absolute
power over both his party and the
country it ruled you've probably already
heard about the infamous purges in which
stalin systematically eliminated
political rivals and basically anyone
else who happened to piss him off
in the most famous of those known as the
great terror as many as 750 000 people
were executed
and more than a million others were sent
to forced labor camps known as gulags
but stalin had other ways of dealing
with people he didn't like beyond simply
murdering them to death
the soviet union covered about 14
of the earth's total land area and the
sheer size of the place gave stalin the
option of banishing people he wanted to
get rid of to the far-flung reaches of
the country
and forgetting all about them
kind of like the evil dictator version
of sticking all the relatives you don't
like as far away as possible on your
wedding seating plan
in all about two million so-called
undesirables were forcibly deported
during the 1930s usually to the endless
wildernesses of siberia
some of these prisoners came from the
soviet union's overflowing jails others
were from social classes or ethnic
minorities stalin was slowly eradicating
and still others were unfortunate enough
to own things the dictator coveted
usually valuable farmland it was one of
those two birds with one stone kind of
affairs
through forced deportation not only did
stalin eliminate those undesirables as a
threat he also used their labor to turn
millions of hectares of barren
wilderness into productive land
or at least
that was the plan
to begin with many of the deportees were
sent to processing camps in tomsk omsk
and a jinx
excuse me
from there they were forwarded on to
newly established settlements across
siberia
hundreds of these settlements appeared
on the soviet map during the 30s and
almost all of them had surrey tales to
tell
but
for the purpose of this video we're only
interested in one
a tiny island in the ob river by the
name of nazino
on the 14th of may 1933 5 000 deportees
from the tomsk camp were rounded up and
packed into four enormous lumber barges
that had been modified to accommodate a
human cargo i say modified they
basically just took all the lumber off
and shoved the people on
anyway with no accommodations suitable
for actual human beings these deportees
were simply shoved below decks and
simply forgotten about
for the 800 kilometer four day journey
along the river up from tomsk to nazino
island
they were given a pitiful food ration of
just five slices of bread per day to
survive on and conditions were so bad
that 27 people were dead before the
barges even reached their destination
with hundreds more in extremely poor
health
after the deadly journey along the ob
it's safe to say the remaining deportees
were prepared for their new
accommodation on the xeno island to be
worthy of a one star trip advisor review
but what they weren't prepared for was
for the accommodation to not actually
exist in the first place
[Music]
as the 5 000 deportees stepped crawled
or were dragged from the lumber barges
onto the island they found themselves on
what was essentially an empty speck of
swampy land in the middle of a freezing
river in siberia
there were no buildings or tents no
toilets or cooking facilities not even
any tools or building materials
just
nothing
to make mata's worst a meager bread
ration that had kept the deportees alive
on the bard's journey
well most of them had pretty much run
out which meant the only remaining food
to feed the 5 000
already nearly starving people on the
island
came in the form of 20 tons of raw flour
the men tasked with handing out this
precious resource nazino island's newly
appointed guards were woefully
unprepared for the task at hand almost
all were rookies who hadn't even been
issued with uniforms yet
and when they first attempted to hand
out the allotted four kilograms of flour
to each prisoner
it's fair to say things didn't exactly
go according to plan
not that that should have come as a big
surprise the deportees were already
suffering from an extreme lack of food
in what was fast becoming a life or
death situation on a frightening scale
rocking up with 20 tons of flour and
trying to give 5 000 people a neat 4
kilograms each
was akin to bringing a shitload of
heroin to a drug den and expecting
everyone to form an orderly queue
as you've probably guessed the poor
souls on the xeno island did not form an
orderly queue they weren't absolutely
[ __ ] mental
a full-scale riot broke out and forced
to admit defeat the guards retreated to
the relative safety of the lumber barges
to devise a new less dangerous plan for
the distribution of the flower all of
which meant that nazino's 5 000 new
inhabitants spent the first night in
their new home without food or shelter
by morning
300 more were dead
the following day the guards made their
second attempt to dish out the flower
the deportees were asked to organize
themselves into brigades of 150 people
each brigade had a self-appointed leader
and each leader was tasked with
collecting enough flower for everyone in
their group
on paper that might sound like a fairly
sensible idea but once again the guards
had overlooked the somewhat crucial
detail that the people of nazino island
were already beginning to starve to
death
to take that drug den analogy one step
further this new ordered approach was a
bit like giving a select group of
addicts a year's supply of heroin then
asking them to share it with a bunch of
random stranger spoiler alert
they didn't
most kept the flower to eat themselves
and use whatever was left as a kind of
pseudo-currency to gain favor with other
powerful deportees
even the apparently lucky ones who
managed to get their hands on some
genuine nazina white powder
had no way of turning it into bread so
they were forced to mix it with river
water and slurp it down as a kind of
paste
the precious calories certainly helped
but the dysentery that resulted from
drinking untreated river water
not so much
within a matter of days the unimaginably
brutal conditions led to a total
breakdown in order
gangs formed around powerful bergrade
leaders and skirmishes were forced over
the island's meager resources as people
died in their hundreds from a
combination of exposure starvation and
disease
the guards were completely out of their
depth and mostly kept to the barges
still they were the ones with the food
and the guns
and that gave them god-like power over
the islanders
a power that predictably enough they
abused at every opportunity
the guards traded food for favors
amongst the island's women
accepted bribes in the form of gold
teeth plucked from the mouths of the
dead and occasionally delivering
and executed hundreds of deportees for
minor infractions
[Music]
despite their brutality the guards were
still outnumbered 100 to 1
and they simply didn't have the manpower
to maintain genuine control
as a result hundreds of people came to
the perfectly reasonable conclusion that
the best way to survive the unfolding
horrors of nazino island
was to get the hell out of there as fast
as possible
not that escape was without risks of its
own
for starters it was punishable by death
and the guard shot anyone they suspected
trying to leave the island on site
then there was a small issue with the
wide fast flowing ice-cold siberian
river that stood between the islanders
and freedom
some fashioned makeshift rafts from bits
and pieces scavenged on the island
and others simply swam for it
almost none made it to the other side
rafts disintegrated in the strong
currents
swimmers weakened by weeks of starvation
were overcome by the freezing waters
and dozens of people were shot by guards
before their escape attempts even got
underway
before long hundreds of bodies lined the
banks of the up down river from the xeno
island
[Music]
in truth even those few lucky ones that
managed to survive the crossing probably
didn't last long in the never-ending
forest that awaited them on the opposite
bank
though at least a couple are thought to
have found their way to safety on
isolated farms
still dying alone in the beautiful
desolate siberian wilderness was almost
certainly preferable to the fate that
awaited those who stayed behind
predictably the pitiful supply of flour
soon ran out
meaning there was quite literally
nothing whatsoever to eat
and that's when the hunting began
on the 21st of may just one week after
the barges brought the first deportees
to nazino island
health inspectors amongst the guards
were tutting up the day's new corpses
when they noticed something disturbing
five of the bodies show telltale signs
of cannibalism
over the course of the following month
more than 50 people were arrested and in
most cases executed for the consumption
of human flesh and they're just the ones
who were actually caught
there are plenty of stories of desperate
people resorting to cannibalism after
finding themselves stranded without food
for long periods
plane crashes in remote areas that sort
of thing
typically cannibalism under these
circumstances comes as a last resort
the weakest member of the group dies of
natural causes and the others make the
impossible decision
to do whatever they have to do to
survive
and that's exactly what happened on the
xeno island
at first
but as time went on the island's most
desperate and depraved inhabitants
stopped waiting for the weak to die
before making their move
those who survived stalin's cannibal
island have unsurprisingly been
reluctant to talk about their
experiences there
but what little information has surfaced
is so horrific
it doesn't even sound real
like eyewitness accounts that speak of
people being tied to trees and butchered
for their meat while still living
you've probably heard of places being
described as hell on earth over the
years
a shopping mall on black friday or a
rough city centre at 1am on a saturday
morning but
for 13 weeks in 1933
nazino island came about as close to the
biblical torment of the fiery pits of
hell as anywhere on earth has ever been
at the end of those 13 weeks of violence
starvation cannibalism and death
it seems the powers that be finally
started to realize that nazino island
wasn't about to be transformed into a
thriving productive community anytime
soon
and so the settlement was dissolved and
barges arrived to take the surviving
deportees away
some 6700 people had been sent to the
island in total the initial 5000 plus
1700 or so more who arrived over the
following weeks
according to official records by the
time the barges arrived to begin
evacuations
2 000 were dead for a combination of
starvation exposure disease murder and
drowning
and the further 2000 has simply
disappeared
it's a safe bet that pretty much all of
the missing perished one way or another
though exactly how they met their ends
nobody will ever know for sure all told
just
2856 people made it out alive and in
most cases it was a close run thing the
vast majority were at death's door
according to a report made at the time
only around 200 could be considered to
be in good physical health
as for what exactly they must have done
for that to be the case
well
i'll leave that up to your imagination
i'd love to be able to tell you that the
suffering was over for those who
survived the horror of nazino island
but sadly
that wasn't the case they were simply
sent to other slightly better organized
settlements elsewhere in siberia
considering what they'd been through
it's no surprise that hundreds more died
before making it to their new homes
many truly terrible things happened in
the soviet union during stalin's reign
of terror
but even on that bloody list the
horrific events that took place on the
xeno island in 1933 stand out and it
seems that fact wasn't lost on stalin
and his advisers either because the
truth about what happened to the nazino
deportees was never made public
and the report into the incident was
buried in the soviet archives for more
than 50 years before being rediscovered
by a human rights group
without their efforts the world might
never have known what really happened on
stalin's cannibal island
and as hard as it is to learn about
something so terrible
those are exactly the kind of atrocities
that we must never forget
[Music]
thank you for watching